come in now if I dunk the rose into
liquid nitrogen 196 degrees centigrade
nearly minus 200 degrees centigrade when
you break it it makes a sort of
satisfying clunk from a chemists point
of view one of the most interesting
things about chocolate is its melting
point chemically mixtures often have
rather ill-defined melting points they
don't melt all at once but with
chocolate it's different and it has a
very sharp melting point so the
chocolate in your hand doesn't melt but
as soon as it gives in your mouth which
is only a little bit warmer than your
hand it melts and it melts very sharply
to give us rather smooth solid smooth
liquid which gives you this very sensual
flavor in your mouth or sensual fuel
another big part of Valentine's Day are
roses and flowers in general but
particularly roses and particularly red
roses the smell molecules are really all
fragrance I should say it's a polite a
word for a nice smell ah really quite
simple molecules they are very volatile
they vaporize very easily so they're
given to the air and you can smell them
so that when people are collecting the
fragrance from roses to make perfume for
example they have to collect the Roses
early in the morning before the Sun has
heated them up and all the smell has
evaporated then usually in the old days
they extracted this fragrance using
hexane which is like a light form of
petrol hexane is more volatile it
evaporates more easily than the
fragrance molecule so it dissolves them
out and then you can allow it to
evaporate and you're left with the
smells and the waxes that come out of
the Roses
my favorite piece of chemistry comes
with these mints you've probably all
seen these rather thin mints which have
chocolate on the outside but if you
break them you can see inside they're
all soft and gooey so think for a moment
how is it possible to put such a nice
layer of chocolate over something that
is so gooey in liquid and it's done with
a very neat chemical trick because the
inside of these chocolates when they're
made and coated is made out of sugar now
when this is mixed up you can make
really quite a stiff paste it's
essentially a solid but it is mixed with
a naturally occurring enzyme called
invertase and when the chocolate coating
has been put on and it's already put
into the box a chemical reaction starts
between the invertase and the sugar the
molecules of sugar consists of two rings
joined together by an oxygen atom in the
middle and the invitees splits these two
rings apart to make two other sugars
fructose and glucose and when these are
mixed together they give you this sort
of liquid and the longer you keep the
Mint's the more and more liquid it gets
so I'm not a specialist in the colors of
roses but you can see that you can get
red ones and you can get all sorts of
different colored roses which have been
bred to give these different colors now
as a chemist I know that these colors
are all viewed two organic compounds
these account compounds of carbon which
might have a little oxygen and nitrogen
as well but the color is usually
associated with a string of double bonds
between the two carbon atoms carbon
atoms can be linked usually a linked
with just a single bond between two
atoms but sometimes you can have a
double bond and occasionally you can
even have a triple bond but a line of
the
double bonds will give rise to color and
the longer the line of the double bonds
or the chain of double bonds in general
the more the color shifts towards the
red different molecules will have
different colors now it's my personal
feeling and this is just a guess but I
think it's very unlikely that people
breeding roses can suddenly persuade a
rose to produce a completely different
compound so it's much more likely that
the rose color is due to a mixture of
several compounds each of which has a
slightly different color if you stop the
rose producing any compounds it will be
white but if you alter the proportion
then I think that you can get these
different colors like orange or yellow
or deep red so a selective breeding will
allow you to vary the proportions but
none of these compounds is blue which is
why without genetic engineering or
something more clever you can't make a
deep blue rose because the colors are
just not in the palette chocolate
contains a compound called theobromine
which is very similar to caffeine the
difference in structure between caffeine
and theobromine is just the position of
one group with containing carbon and
three hydrogen's so chemically they're
quite similar and so that the effect of
theobromine is also to heighten the
effect of eating the chocolates but
theobromine is a stimulant and it is
forbidden for racehorses so if you feed
a chocolate bar to your racehorse if
you're rich enough to have one then if
the horse wins the race
it may be disqualified because they can
detect theobromine in the horse's urine
when they do a drug test
roses are quite amusing for chemists
because you can do quite a nice trick
with them now if I dunk the rose
into liquid nitrogen which is at minus
196 degrees centigrade nearly minus 200
degrees centigrade the nitrogen starts
boiling and the cold gas comes out and
nitrogen is completely colorless but it
can dead the coal gas condense water
vapors so you see what looks like like
smoke so if we take it out now it's gone
quite brittle as if they just bang it it
now breaks into little pieces because
the water in the leaves will in the
petals have frozen so I'm not sure why
people use this expression that the
chemistry is right I think it's because
in chemistry different atoms and
different compounds combine together to
form really stable molecules or
complexes so just in the same way if you
get the right two people they will react
together and give a very stable
combination some of the others may give
something that's a bit more volatile or
occasionally a pairing that's even
explosive but that's what makes
chemistry fun and it's what makes
relations fun as well